the treatments for tetralogy of fellow
are surgical procedures to help fix the
following four heart problems
a ventricular septal defect or vsd is a
hole in the wall between the two
ventricles
and overriding aorta happens when the
aorta is located directly over the
ventricular septal defect this means the
aorta is connected to both the left and
right ventricles instead of its normal
attachment to only the left ventricle
in pulmonary stenosis the main pulmonary
artery is narrowed
and the pulmonary valve doesn't open all
the way
and right ventricular hypertrophy means
the wall of the right ventricle is
thicker than normal
tetralogy of follow is repaired with
open heart surgery either soon after
birth or in infancy
surgical procedures may include
temporary and complete repairs
your child may not be ready for a
complete repair right away
in this case a temporary repair such as
a shunt or a stent can be placed until a
complete repair can be done both repairs
increase blood flow to the lungs and
improve oxygen levels in the blood
delivered to the body
during a shunt procedure the surgeon
will open the chest wall to place a tube
called a shunt between a branch of the
aorta and the right pulmonary artery
the shunt will provide another path for
blood to get to the lungs to pick up
oxygen
during a stent procedure a tube called a
catheter will be inserted through a
small incision into a blood vessel in
the leg
the cardiologist will use the catheter
to place a device called a stent inside
the narrowed area of the pulmonary
artery
this allows more blood to flow to the
lungs
a complete repair is done when your
child is strong enough for the procedure
during the procedure the pulmonary
stenosis defect may be repaired in the
following ways
if the main pulmonary artery is too
small it will be widened with a patch
if the pulmonary valve is too small it
may be widened with a patch or replaced
if extra heart muscle is blocking blood
flow below the pulmonary valve the
surgeon will remove the muscle tissue
these repairs will improve the flow of
oxygen poor blood from the right
ventricle to the lungs as a result the
blood will get enough oxygen for the
body's needs
to fix the ventricular septal defect the
surgeon will cover the hole with a patch
the patch will prevent the mixing of
oxygen poor blood with oxygen-rich blood
as a result only oxygen-rich blood will
flow out of the aorta to the body from
the left ventricle
over time fixing the pulmonary stenosis
and closing the ventricular septal
defect will also fix the right
ventricular hypertrophy
since the right ventricle won't have to
work as hard to pump blood its wall will
return to normal thickness
if your child still has a shunt from the
temporary repair
it will either be removed or clipped
shut at the end of this procedure
similarly if your child had a stent
placed
it will also be removed
to find out more about treatment for
tetralogy of fallow talk to your health
care provider